-My man. Here we go.
Drumroll.
-Hey, Jimmy!
-Yeah!
-I'm Jimmy!
Yes!
-I'm sorry.
I'm not picking favorites.
I'm not.
No, I don't have a favorite.
Thank you very much.
I appreciate it.
-Come closer.
Touch my hand
and look at the camera.
That's it.
-That's it?
Wow.
-Let's go.
-I do that at a concert?
Alright. Ready?
You ready?
♪♪
-You okay? You okay?
Now BTS is gonna show me
the Idol dance. Here we go.
-Okay.
...6, 7, 8.
1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6, 7, 8.
-Here we go. Ready?
-5, 6, 7, 8.
♪ Oh, oh, ooh-oh, hey! ♪
♪ Oh, oh, ooh-whoa, whoa ♪
-I'm in the band.
I'm in the band.
Let's go!
♪♪
[ Indistinct conversations ]
-So we got some
sandwiches here.
-Thank you.
-When these are ready,
just yell, "Order up."
-Order up.
-And then you come.
You grab it and you book it.
-Order up!
-Go, go, go, go, go, go.
-BTS made it for you.
Hey! What's happening?!
-Order up!
-Oh, no, no, no, no.
I'm coming. I'm coming.
[ All yelling indistinctly ]
-From BTS.
Please enjoy.
-Jimmy!
♪♪
-Good work.
-Let's go.
-Oh.
-Before BTS,
what did you want to be?
-Jimmy...
-What would you do?
Host a talk show?
-Maybe.
-Don't take my job.
Don't take my job.
Oh,
-Jimin Fallon.
-Jimin Fallon?
Did you ever think BTS
would become this big?
-No. Never.
-No.
-Never.
-When you doubted yourself,
what got you to
the next level of like,
"Hey, I can do this"?
What is the black bean
noodle incident?
-Ah, yeah.
-I had a stomachache.
-So...
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-How long did you go away?
-Um, I don't know,
like, 3 or 4 minutes.
That's not that long.
And, you know, I was like,
"Get me noodles as fast
as you can,"
and, you know...
-It was so fast.
-Yeah. Swallowed it
and, yeah. Boom.
-Is there something you do
before every performance?
Can you show me?
-You want to do it together?
-I'll do it with you.
-Okay.
-Come here. Come here.
-So we go -- We go down.
We don't go up.
So we go down.
When I say...
And you guys say...
You say [speaks Korean]
-[Speaks Korean]
So when I say [speaks Korean]
you say [speaks Korean]
Okay, we go down.
-Oh. Come on.
-Go!
-Hey, my son.
-Oh.
-I got that one, right?
-Hey.
-Talk to me about B,
I want to know about B.
-Yo, Jimmy and Fallon.
Let's go.
-Jimmy Fallon.
-Jimmy.
-Last time you were
on our show,
the world was a different place.
We went all over New York City,
Grand Central Terminal,
Katz's Deli.
We were on the subway.
Do you have a favorite
part of that day?
-Grand Central.
-Yeah.
-Subway.
-Hey, wake up.
-Jimmy.
-Good boy. Good boy.
Jimin, that's awesome.
Respect. Respect.
-Jimin good boy.
-Me too good boy.
-You bad boy.
-Jimin, what were you like
in high school?
Go!
♪♪
Jimin wins.
-Go!
-Alright, here we go.
13 seconds.
We got 10 s-- 10 seconds.
-Oh.
-My gosh.
Jimin, hurry up!
[ Indistinct yelling ]
Jimin, you're such a cheater.
Can you look at yourselves here?
And which one of you guys
is wearing the sunglasses
in the darkest room
I've ever seen in my life?
-Oh.
-Actually it's me.
And it's very hilarious.
-Boo!
-Jimin! Jimin, turn around!
Jimin, turn around.
Jimin, look at what --
-Oh, be confident.
Be confident.
-Oh. Oh, my goodness.
It's great.
But what goes through your mind
when you see something --
I won't show it anymore.
But what do you think
when you see that?
That was only eight years ago.
Not too long ago.
Yeah.
-We got --
Actually, we think
we got handsome.
-Yeah.
No, you --
[ Cheers and applause ]
No, no, no.
I think --
I think
you've always had that.
I think you always had that.
Jimin, when you guys were
deciding on stage names,
is it true that you almost
decided to go with Baby J?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, yeah.
-What else was in the running?
Well, if you decide
to make it longer,
you can go with Jimin Fallon.
Jimin -- Jimin Fallon.
Thank you. That's perfect.
That's -- That's what we all --
That's the goal of this
whole thing.
All these years,
that's the goal.
-Hi, I'm Jimin Fallon.
-Yeah, why not? Why not?
-♪ Will it fit down ♪
-Yeah.
-Here's how it works.
Jimin, you're up first.
Your -- Your objects are...
-Will 33 sticks of butter
fit in a fishbowl?
-Yeah.
-He says yes!
Alright, here we go.
Let's see if you can get 33
sticks of butter in a fishbowl.
Whenever you're ready, go!
-Let's go, go, go, go, go, go.
Will 33 sticks of butter fit
in the fishbowl?
Force them to fit.
-Oh.
-Be careful.
-Yes. He made it fit.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Yeah. Oh, hi.
Oh, Jimin.
What are you doing here?
-Can I come in?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, sure. Yeah.
Come on in.
[ Ominous music plays ]
♪♪
Have a seat. Have a seat.
Oh, let me clear
this out for you.
Here. Have a seat.
Oh, sorry.
-You okay?
-Yeah, I'm great.
I'm happy you're back
in the show.
I mean, you have new music out.
Of course I didn't know that.
No one knew that.
I mean, it's out March 24th.
It's called "Face."
It's pretty awesome.
I heard the single,
but you want a drink?
-Oh, sure.
-Maybe. Yeah.
A drink would be good.
I'll get you a --
Wow. That's odd.
Your face is on the can,
but, look,
maybe I'll get you a snack.
-Dr. Jimin?
-A snack will be good.
You know what?
Let me e-mail my assistant,
and I can get a snack
or get something to eat.
Maybe we'll have to --
Whoa. This website's up.
That shouldn't be there.
Today is so funny.
Okay, let me get this off.
Let's -- That's your song.
Well, that's your song.
Of course you know that.
But that's not --
Louder. Louder now.
You know what? Maybe it's better
if I just see you out there.
I'll see you out on the floor.
-Good. Good idea.
-Thank you. Bye.
-See ya.
-Thank you. See ya.
♪♪
-Jimmy. So cool.
-Whoo!
♪♪
-Our next guest...
[ Audience screaming ]
Wow.
...is a 5-time...
[ Screaming continues ]
...Grammy-nominated artist
and a global pop-music icon
that you know from BTS.
His debut --
His debut solo album,
"Face," is out now!
Please welcome Jimin!
-♪ Here we go,
face to face, oh ♪
♪ Here we go, face to face ♪
♪ Here we go,
face to face, oh ♪
♪ Here we go, face to face ♪
♪ Here we go,
face to face, oh ♪
♪ Here we go, face to face ♪
♪ Here we go,
face to face, oh ♪
♪ Here we go, face to face ♪
♪ Here we go,
face to face, oh ♪
♪ Here we go, face to face ♪
♪ Here we go,
face to face, oh ♪
♪ Here we go, face to face ♪
♪♪
-Wow!
Wow.
-Wow.
-Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Welcome -- Yeah.
Jimin --
Jimin, welcome back to the show.
Thank you so much
for being here.
-Thank you.
-The last time you were here
was a big deal.
It was the first time
you were nominated for a Grammy.
And I think the first time
you were on our show,
you were like,
"I really want a Grammy."
Now you're 5 time nominated
for a Grammy.
-Wow.
-Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Congratulations.
-Thank you. Thank you, Jimmy.
We could be nominated,
thanks to our fans.
Great support.
I appreciate them.
[ Audience screaming ]
-Yeah, I will say you have --
You have the greatest fans.
-Yeah.
-You had --
Yeah, yeah, they are the best.
[ Screaming continues ]
More --
I'm sure more Grammy nominations
on the way by the way.
This is fantastic.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And thank you for always
being supportive of us
because we have similar names.
So I'm very, very excited,
but I know the rest of the guys
are concentrating on
their solo projects currently.
But are you in contact?
Do you talk every day?
-We keep in touch.
-Yeah?
With who?
With who, in particular?
-With J-Hope.
[ Cheers and applause ]
With Suga, everyone.
-I want to talk
about your new album.
But I also --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. "Face."
But I want to know
more of your story.
Okay? I was --
Was making music
always the plan for...
[ Screaming continues ]
Look at this guy.
-So cute.
-Yeah.
-This is me.
Was making music always
the plan for this little man?
And also, when did you realize
how talented you were?
-When I was in middle school.
-Yeah.
-I found interesting dance.
And since then, it was always
my dream to perform on stage.
-Yeah, always.
And could you imagine
how big it's gotten?
Yeah. No, no.
It's the biggest thing
in the world.
Jimin, you have a lot
of nicknames, by the way.
Mo-- Mochi?
-Mochi!
-Chim Chim.
-Little Prince.
-Little Prince?
-Yeah.
Yes. Dooly.
-Dooly?
-Dooly.
Yeah. That's one of your --
Do you have a favorite nickname?
-My favorite nickname
is Jimin Fallon.
[ Laughter ]
-I didn't make it say that.
I did not make him say that.
That's so good. Thank you.
Over the summer,
you and the rest of the guys
got to go
to the White House and...
meet with the president,
Joe Biden.
That is such a big deal.
Was it --
How important
and how big was this for you?
-Oh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
People --
People go nuts for you.
They freak out
when they see you.
I was --
[ Audience screaming ]
He's right here! I know!
I freak out.
I'm freaking out, too.
I'm freaking out right now.
Is there anyone that you --
that you have met
that you get starstruck
when you've met?
-Oh, first Jimmy Fallon.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Maybe you.
You're so funny and sweet.
-Thank you.
-And...
-Who for real, though?
[ Laughter ]
-And Halsey.
-Halsey.
-Oh, really?
-She has --
She has a big heart.
And she has the talent
that would make
anyone starstruck.
-Yeah.
-All our members love her.
-Yeah, everyone loves her.
We love Halsey, too.
Let's talk about
your new album, "Face."
-This is...
[ Cheers and applause ]
It is officially out now.
It is out.
-Out now!
-It's out!
-Can you -- I know.
Can you talk about
the inspiration for this album
and what it represents to you?
Absolutely.
Yeah.
And when you have a new song,
do you play it
for the rest of BTS?
And do you listen
to anyone else?
-Um...
[ Laughter ]
-A little bit?
-Maybe.
-I have a question for you.
This is an honest question.
I didn't prepare this,
but I have this problem,
and I want to know
if you can help me.
I go to a concert
and I feel like I'm too old
to go to a show.
I just don't know --
Well, here's -- Help me out.
I have a problem.
I go to a concert, I don't know
how to dance at a concert.
And I was wondering if you could
maybe teach me a dance
that could be --
I could do anywhere.
-Oh, sure.
-You could?
-Okay. Stand up. Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Here.
Okay.
-Okay. Yeah.
-Let's go.
-Okay.
-Come closer.
Touch my hand.
And look at the camera.
That's it.
-That's it?
Wow.
I do that at a concert?
Alright. Ready? Ready?
♪♪
Evening, everybody.
"Face" is out now!